all right gonna give you my quick
thoughts well I always say quick
thoughts sometimes I say quick thoughts
the video ends up being seven minutes
like ten I don't mean for that to happen
I just do what I do just ramble until I
feel like I've said enough but after a
couple of glimpses among some HBO Sizzle
reels we have ourselves our first actual
trailer of The Last of Us series on HBO
which last of a series that's good after
Decades of failed attempt at adapting
video games into movies some of them are
better than others I get that I don't
give a [ __ ] in retrospect Street Fighter
the movie some people call it the Van
Damme Street Fighter I used to at this
point I call it the raw Julia Street
Fighter that's Raul Julie elevating that
content but it's like everyone learned
okay movies that that's not enough time
to adapt 15 to 40 hours of gameplay
let's do a series and even then
sometimes the series is like that's not
the thing what I liked about this
trailer is I mean the tone is there the
tone absolutely is recognizable as the
last of us I guess I don't know I should
call it the atmosphere more than the
tone point is I'm watching the trailer
and I'm like I feel like I know what I'm
looking at I feel like I did play that
part which is important you want your
target audience to feel that your target
audience is people who played the game
you don't want your audience to be like
I I don't recognize this at all this is
The Last of Us keeping in mind movie
trailers are commercials for a product
so obviously they're going to make the
product look as good as humanly possible
kind of like in the commercials the Big
Mac always looks juicy and amazing then
you get the Big Mac you're like what the
[ __ ] is that sometimes that's the same
contrast between movie trailers and the
movies but this Last of Us trailer looks
familiar to the game and that's the
point you look at the creature models
you're like that's from the game it
would have been so easy to make the
world feel like this generic
post-apocalyptic dystopian Zombie World
I know it's not zombies they're infected
with a parasite it is different
but still that's that's my point that
music in that trailer that does help the
song is alone and forsaken by Hank
Williams which is the song that played
in one of the trailers to the original
Last of Us it very much reminds me of
when Hurt by Johnny Cash played in the
trailer to Logan I call it lonely Broody
guy in a fallen World sitting in the
corner of a dark room slamming a fifth
of Tennessee whiskey music and if I can
think of Joel well that is the guy and
seeing the trailer I think the cast
looks good too I mean with the last of
us I always had my fan casting as well
and I wouldn't have picked Pedro Pascal
is one of those oh yeah Josh Brolin
obviously when they ever make a movie or
a series but we know the dude has talent
so I gotta have faith that this is an
opportunity for him to do something
truly special in the end the biggest
selling point is that right there
because Chernobyl is one of the greatest
limited series ever created I think it
is how did the architect say it was
quite naturally perfect it was a work of
art right exactly then you have the
original Last of Us it was quite
naturally perfect it was a work of art
sounds like a match made in heaven in a
world of hell if you look at it it is
the same kind of horror Chernobyl was
very horror based on atmosphere and tone
The Last of Us horror based on
atmosphere and tone I mean yeah you have
clickers and hard people coming after
you but even when they weren't coming
after you the horror was still there and
so I feel like there is a connective
tissue there's a connective link of DNA
between Chernobyl and The Last of Us
creatively speaking and for nothing else
I feel like this can be this could be
the moment where everybody understands
everybody because a Pedro Pascal is
crushing it as Joel the internet
everybody Twitter they're all going to
be like he's amazing he's incredible
then the first episode of season two
happens they're gonna be like what the
[ __ ] what why did that happen exactly
all right so this teaser trailer for the
HBO series The Last of Us have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]